c'est au fond de son garage transformé
en atelier que jean-marie des shows à
installer sont établis ancien maçon il
s'est trouvé un passe temps qui lui
permet de continuer à exercer son métier
de bâtisseur il reproduit au 1/25 des
constructions anciennes en pierre de
bourgogne un matériau qu'il n'a aucun
mal à se procurer sinon celui d'avoir à
se baisser pour le ramasser dans son
jardin après avoir passé motoculteurs
qu'à remonter pierre forcément pige en
retrouve un on a une région qui avec un
championnat réputé pour sa et jean-marie
deschaux a commencé par faire des
cadolles petite maison de vignes
traditionnelle dans le châtillonnais
parmi ses plus belles réalisations le
haut fourneau de marcenais un édifice de
1742 qui existe toujours et qui a
fonctionné jusqu'au début du siècle
dernier
l'église paroissiale saint germain
d'auxerre construite aux 15ème et 16ème
siècle à points sont les l'art est
étonnamment reconstitué dans ses
moindres détails jusqu'à l'intérieur
avec ses bancs et même son curé
et puis cette ferme du 19e siècle dans
tous les éléments peuvent être démontée
ses dimensions grange écurie habitation
avec une pierre évier sous la fenêtre
comme dans l'ancien temps une exacte
réplique des bâtisses d'autrefois
fils et petit fils de maçon jean-marie
des shows maîtrise les règles de l'art
je me souviens mon père allait d'aller
les bois cherchait des pertes souffert
d'échafaudages et y avaient assisté par
causé la corde
c'était vraiment comme si c'était sous
d1 pour ses échafaudages light avec lé
trou mais triboulet on appelle ça les
boulahia des coudes dans le mur qui
laissait à burg qui mentait et très
voyait pour les chapardages la part de
tpe et de céder tout pour des trous dans
les murs mais aussi en triangle au
dessus des fenêtres
mais pourquoi qu'on appelle une décharge
pour pas que ça appuie sur le plateau
sinon il n'ya pas seule une a tué la
longue vie à des petits mouvements du
bâtiment mobile et pourquoi des pierres
proéminente sur les façades tlb père
quitte à verser des deux parements note
le mur était beaucoup plus solide
si le propriétaire du bâtiment paient
bien avoir une peuplade pierre qui
paient pour boire il n'était pas clair
du tout des techniques de construction
sauver de l'oubli mais aussi des
accessoires indispensables dans ce
pigeonnier par exemple à l'intérieur des
nichoirs tout au tout les pigeons
avaient une échelle tourne encore aller
récupérer les oeufs ou les pigeons peut
faire quelque chose ça peut pas être 3 1
enfin c'est pas possible
un travail de patience long et minutieux
un an pour la ferme qui pèse une
centaine de kilos un an aussi pour
l'église
cette collection qui devrait encore
s'agrandir accueille parfois des groupes
de visiteurs et des ménages de temps en
temps pour être exposées dans les villes
et villages alentours
[Musique]